- Because of professional development
at Kettle Moraine,
teachers have the skills
and the tools that they need
to really meet the needs
of all of our students.
Everyone is working towards
creating a culture of growth,
and taking risks to interact and
engage with their class
as a whole.
At Kettle Moraine, we have a
vision of continuous growth.
Whether that's students,
teachers, it's about
how can we get there together.
Visible learning is a strategy where staff
will actually get behind a camera and
have the opportunity to look at themselves
and to watch and reflect on
their teaching practices.
- It helps me see what
the learning looks like
in my classroom through a different lens.
We did a few test filming sessions
and I saw students all over the
place, as far as engagement.
And, so, for my goal I chose to try to increase
student engagement through
use of vocabulary words.
More vocabulary, I've
defined as more engaged.
When students walk into
the classroom, it is nice
to let them know, like hey,
I'm going to be filming you today.
They are all part of the
process and I share my goal
with them as well.
I'm usually filming about thirty
minutes of discussion time;
so I can see who's really interacting,
if they're writing things
down, if they're drawing,
if they're showing each
other different things.
- [Woman] The swivel is set
up for an iPhone or an iPad.
Sometimes, teachers choose to have the camera on students
and then, sometimes they will
put the camera on themselves.
So that really just depends
on what their goal is.
- We often fall into the habit
of making assumptions about
what's going on in the classroom.
And visible learning gives
us a chance to see our habits
and our patterns and recognize
maybe why they aren't effective all the time.
Just having a little bit
of a shift in our practice
can lead to gains on the students' part.
- It's really important
for a teacher to have
the ability to reflect on
what they're seeing initially.
It just allows teachers
to get comfortable with
the experience.
- I try to watch those films on
the same day they've been recorded.
Just so they're fresh in my mind.
What I do is I watch it through once
without really tracking anything.
The second time through is
really when I start to track.
I'm gonna stop the video
every minute and tally
which students are authentically engaged
and which students are not.
I'm writing down which vocabulary
words they're using
and what I was seeing on film
was a lot of non-engagement
with their peers.
- After a teacher watches
their video, they meet with the coach
to talk through some of their ideas.
To get another set of eyes
either on what they think
that they're seeing in the classroom
or some possible solutions.
- In order to change the
students' interaction in class,
I needed to give a little bit
more direct instruction on
how to interact with your peers
and how to use science vocabulary words.
- Individually, the teacher
is going to be the one that
determines what
that success looks like.
- Visible learning gives us a chance
to reflect on our practice, to align
what we believe is happening
in the classroom
to what really is happening.
And also, it gives us a chance to adapt
to reach as many students as possible.
- [Bearded Teacher] We are all trying to grow
in our professional career
and it's all gonna help
the students at the end of the day.
And that's really the goal of
the whole teaching process.